foreign
hello and welcome to the view from 22 a
spectator show where we like to look at
a story that isn't necessarily
dominating the news but this week we
thought we'd do the exact opposite
because there is only one story that has
dominated the globe so far and that of
course is the indictment of President
Donald J Trump
I'm delighted to be joined by Alan
dershowitz who is a very distinguished
lawyer and the author of get Trump the
threat to civil liberties due process
and our constitutional rule of law and
we're also joined by Charles Lipson who
is a professor of political science and
a much-loved spectator contributor
now Alan uh you as the author of get
Trump uh are well aware of the fact that
there has been seven years eight years
maybe of attempts to get Trump legally
through various different trials and
prosecutions
um but it finally happened yesterday
last night and I think it's fair to say
the sort of mood even among the people
who hate Trump the most was a bit muted
uh is there a sort of widespread feeling
that this case is thin and even people
who hate Donald Trump accept that it's
thin
well I was hoping there'd be a strong
indictment I'm not as Trump supporter I
voted against them and it would
vindicate the American legal system and
the New York Criminal Justice System but
uh the D.A has labored and has produced
a mouse uh and uh it's an extremely weak
indictment the basic theory behind the
indictment is that once Trump paid 130
000 in hush money to prevent his family
his wife his business partners from
learning about an alleged adulterous
Affair he should immediately have then
made it public in his corporate forms no
one in the history of the world has ever
done that and yet the district attorney
really expected that of him we've had
thousands of hush payments made starting
with Alexander Hamilton early in our
history uh and up through Uh current uh
corporate leaders nobody in history is
ever then disclosed it on a corporate
form and that yet that lies at the
center of this um
frivolous indictment against him
remember the man who indicted him ran
for office on the ground that look I'm a
Democrat I promise to get Trump I'll
stop him from running for office and
then uh he decided to get Trump uh and
rummaged through all the statute books
found nothing and then just made up a
technical crime that doesn't really
exist well yeah I I read the indictment
and I don't have a legal mind but it
looked unbelievably thin particularly
since I've been speaking to some people
who are sort of get Trump types and they
were hopeful possibly even some of them
convinced that there would be something
in these 34 counts that was new and
explosive but it just wasn't there was
it
it's not there and uh no matter how you
stretch it no matter how many counts you
put down it's essentially the same thing
the expectation that if you've paid hush
money you're they're going to put the
reason the actual reason on your
corporate form uh and then he
extrapolates that into the reason he
really entered the form fraudulently was
to help his campaign had nothing to do
with his wife or his family or his
business it's such a stretch in 60 years
of uh litigating and teaching in
criminal cases I've never seen a thinner
indictment than this or one that was so
based on who the person is rather than
what the crime was you know there were
crimes committed uh probably Stormy
Daniels extorted him uh by threatening
to expose it in exchange for money the
34 counts the fact that they were 34
counts leaked the only people who could
have leaked that would be people in
Bragg's office or people in the grand
jury that's a more serious felony than
any anything you charge Trump with so
we're seeing selective targeted
Injustice here and it's a very very bad
day and we'll talk about the bad day for
America in a second but just quickly the
motion a motion to dismiss would be the
next obvious uh move would it not and it
should be that will fail that will fail
because no judge will want to be the one
who people can point their finger to and
say he's the judge who freed Donald
Trump look I defended Donald Trump once
on the floor of the Senate and it
destroyed years and years of friendships
business associations ability to write
for newspapers I was completely canceled
just for
defending Trump on constitutional
grounds in front of the Senate imagine
how much worse it would be for a judge
an elected judge remember we elect our
judges an elected judge to run on the
claim that he's the one who freed Donald
Trump in the borough of Manhattan so I
think that motion will fail the Motions
that have a chance of succeeding are the
change of venue to a different area of
New York or the statute of limitations
which seems like a very strong motion
but these motions may not work in front
of the judge they may have to wait until
after the case is over and the appeal is
conducted by that time we'll be right in
the middle of the 2024 election campaign
so this really does interfere with an
election and when you do that and you're
a Democrat and you're trying to defeat a
republican you better have the strongest
possible case this is not a strong case
it's a very very and we should say you
are a lifelong Democrat who did not vote
for Donald Trump in 10 2016 is that
right uh although I think Trump likes to
say that you only say that to to get
more credibility but it's true uh
Charles the future of America a lot of a
lot of Despair yesterday about America
and uh you know what this means for
democracy and so on do you share that
sense of dread
um if you live in Chicago you shared for
a second reason we just elected a far
left mayor who's a union organizer for
the teachers union but um
of course the far bigger issue for the
country is what has happened to uh uh
the indictment of Donald Trump I too am
know Trump supporter and I think there
are strong cases against Donald Trump uh
especially
the issue related to Mar-A-Lago which is
not just that he kept documents which it
appears he had no right to keep but that
he made a formal declaration that he did
not have any more documents when he not
only had them but must have known that
he had them because somewhere in his
desk the issue in a second indictment
that is likely to come uh is in Georgia
whether
uh he attempted illegally uh to uh ask
State uh lawmakers in charge of uh the
vote count in 2020 to find him votes
that really weren't there now he will
say that he meant find votes that had
somehow been suppressed and that he was
only seeking uh legal votes but uh
that's a and so that's a more complex
case but uh I think
what happened last night in America
which is that Donald Trump went and uh
did what he so often does which is he
personalized the issue
he attacked not only the judge and the
prosecutor but their families by name
um these kinds of things are just
outrageous and
um at some point you have to fear
um either that there could be violence
directed at those people
or uh that the American voting public
especially the Republican voters who
would vote in a primary just decide
we've had enough of this so far they've
decided to Rally around
um Donald Trump that's a kind of rally
around the flag Effect one the the real
question there is how long that will
last well we've had quite a lot of
warnings of uh you know violence uh in
the last few days and of course
everybody will think back to January the
6th and uh that's that's obviously quite
a a grave concern but uh last night
there was an enormous police presence uh
there was no
um significant violence and there was no
real threat of significant violence
isn't this a slight kind of democratic
fantasy that uh Trump is is you know
fermenting violence everywhere he goes
well to some extent you're uh I agree
with that uh with what you're saying uh
Freddie but there's another aspect to it
which is
uh first of all we're taking more and
more of our political issues and moving
them into the legal setting the legal
context they're being decided uh in the
courts and worse they're being decided
by uh bureaucracies law enforcement
bureaucracies like the FBI uh and
um some that shouldn't be involved in
domestic politics like the CIA and so
forth that's a problem but I think that
equally important problem is that people
are in the United States and I know this
has happened in Britain and it's
happened in Continental Europe as well
have lost a lot of their trust in
governmental institutions
and in other institutions like the media
um the only institution in the United
States that has more than 50 percent
approval is the U.S military
every other institution
is not just underwater there are no
bubbles coming up from underwater That's
How far underwater they are and that's a
grave thing and what you have time and
again from Donald Trump is sort of a
frontal assault on many of these
institutions not on policy grounds not
on the grounds that
um they have accrued to themselves more
power than they should legitimately have
but on very fundamental grounds they're
against us and all all the rest I've got
to say I completely agree
with Allah dershowitz on this uh
particular indictment in New York the
the biggest problem that he is
underscoring in my opinion is not just
that the indictment is thin but that it
is bass awkwards as we say it began with
a person
and then they found the crime that's
never supposed to happen in the
anglo-american system of justice or any
Western system of justice this is not
just a Relentless prosecutor
but in New York the two leading
prosecutors on the state level Leticia
James the attorney general and the
Manhattan prosecutor Alvin Bragg
campaign on the grounds that they were
going to get this particular person and
then they found they have worked to find
something to get it well that's that's a
very good point and I wanted to ask you
about that because I mean there's a
bridge as an outsider we look at the
American justice system and it does
strike us odd that you have uh elected
judges that you have uh the justice
system is so democratized
um and I suppose what strikes me is that
it's it's more uh extraordinary that
this hasn't happened more and more often
um that the the judicial process is so
flagrantly political
um
well it has it has happened it happened
since the days of Andrew Jackson
Remember the United States was
established not as a democracy the word
democracy never appears in any of the
urged original documents it became a
democracy under what's called Jacksonian
Democracy and they went crazy elect
judges like prosecutors you know in
Florida you elect the public defender
can you imagine the campaign candidate a
I took dershowitz's classes he taught me
everything if you elect me I'll free
every murder or rapist and Robber
candidate B I failed out of law school
I'm a terrible lawyer if you elect me
all the bad guys will go to jail you
don't elect public defenders and you
don't elect judges and you don't elect
prosecutors if you want Justice the
British system is far far better where
you have career prosecutors where you
have a director of public prosecution
it's a much more credible and it's much
more sound we should borrow the British
system of justice much like Britain has
borrowed some of our systems but we
impose the wrong system you cannot have
democracy in a court of law it's not
what the people want in communist
countries democracy I went to a Chinese
trial and once the evidence was in they
opened the doors and they had the masses
come in and say guilty guilty guilty
that's the matter Allen but that's Alan
when I was growing up uh the local
justices of the Peace were paid only if
they convicted you
that's right there was this I've got to
tell you that your chances of being
found not guilty or as uh Nancy Pelosi
was so eloquently put it proving your
innocence good Lord and that those
chances approached zero
yeah no but you know the American system
of justice can often be quite fair but
with Trump derangement syndrome
um and people half the country
determined to see Donald Trump in prison
you're not going to get a fair trial and
if 87 percent of the people of the
borough of Manhattan want to see him in
prison you're just not going to get a
fair trial it took a Supreme Court
decision to actually rule
unconstitutional these rules where
people got paid by how many convictions
they got it was part of our system
it happened to me I can tell you that I
had a Justice as a piece I was on my way
to a concert in Memphis
uh Rock and Roll concert and I was with
a bunch of friends and I had the justice
of the peace actually have all of us in
the car take out our wallets
see how much money we all had
and then
we had to negotiate with him to leave us
enough money to pay for the parking in
Memphis
yeah I had a similar situation when I
was a civil rights worker down in the
South uh our car was stopped and uh we
were taken in and and had to pay
whatever we had in our pocket no kidding
I didn't realize we had this in common
the same the same very same situation
but you know I would hope that the
indictment of trump maybe May Market
change I think a lot of Americans
Democrats liberals people who don't like
Trump like me who don't vote for Trump
like me
maybe having an epiphany maybe saying
too much is too much and maybe we'll
learn a lesson from this and maybe we
can help turn it around I'm the eternal
optimist I hope it will happen but I am
confident that Trump cannot get a fair
trial in Manhattan and that has to be
the first step we take to avoid
multiplying the Injustice of the kind
we've already seen I think am I right in
saying there's a New York expression if
you're not indicted you're not invited
have you
well you know there are a lot of New
York Expressions uh and there's one that
if you think you can get a fair trial in
New York for Donald Trump I have a
bridge to Brooklyn that I'll sell you uh
there there is no possibility of that
happening and my friends who are
liberals and Democrats agree with that
they just want to see him convicted I
had somebody who said to me I know it
will destroy the Constitution but it's
worth it because preventing Donald Trump
from becoming president is more
important than preserving the
constitution in my book at Trump I
actually quote people making those kinds
of statements that Donald Trump is like
Adolf Hitler and you can do and should
do anything to stop him from becoming
president that's a mindset that is
inconsistent and it is it has become
much more pervasive not just around
Trump but around a lot of issues I would
say one of the most fundamental changes
in American politics in the past several
decades has been that it has become much
more ideological
along European lines Freddie
um yes uh our politics used to be a lot
of meat in the center it was mediated by
a political institutions and so forth
like big city political machines and and
so forth you can say many things
negative about them but they had
um
they were not ideological operations
they were patronage operations they
would give jobs to your friends in the
African-American Community or
irish-american Community or whatever
but we are now much more similar to a
kind of Labor versus Tory or left-right
european social democracy versus
uh Christian democrats but and there are
fights deep fights within both parties
around these issues say one more thing
about Trump
Trump fundamentally changed the
Republican party and that's not just
about his personality the Republican
party used to be the party of big
business big business is now firmly in
support of the Democrats on everything
except taxing big business
but
um the
um what Trump did was shifted
the politics of the Republican Party
toward a working-class base and the
Democrats
are I would say split and the
Republicans are split on in their own
way but the Democrats are now split and
I would say the two people that people
observers tend to put on the same side
they tend to say well on the left are
people like Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders but to me and and in many issues
they are but to me the difference is
that Bernie Sanders is fundamentally a
left-wing populist
and Elizabeth Warren is fundamentally a
regulatory State left Winger
and uh you see this kind of split
between the AOC wing of the party
and the Nancy Pelosi type wing and they
try to bridge it and on the Republican
side you see it between the fire brands
on the right who are essentially
populous and the Mitch McConnells who
are essentially a
center-right much more uh uh aligned
with the corporatist wing of the party
so I I think that Trump brings out and
Trump has done fundamental things to
change the nature of American politics
hmm there's a lot of speculation
obviously that um the Democrats uh wants
Trump to be in the frame and that's part
of the this conspiracy to to get him is
that they know that it helps him in the
polls and they know that it makes him
the candidate they're most likely to
face and that's ultimately what the
people around Joe Biden want because
they think they can beat him do you
believe that
look Biden is a very very weak candidate
and a strong Republican candidate uh
would be likely to beat him under
current circumstances
uh but Trump is actually a very weak
candidate in the general election and
the reason for that is not only that
young voters are staunchly opposed to
him in overwhelming numbers but so are
many educated and upper income voters
and even just middle-income voters who
live in the suburbs and so forth I think
the the longer term impact of all these
indictments which are likely to come
is that people will simply associate
Trump with more and more tummeled
and Trump is himself so undisciplined
that
um
that all of his campaign right now is
about revenge people don't elect
uh leaders for the next four years to
exact revenge and if they did it would
be a terrible thing
uh for a democracy they elect people to
solve problems like inflation
uh like uh Rising interest rates like
um what are we going to do about China
what are we going to do about uh support
for Ukraine big looming issues we have
failing education system in virtually
all big cities we have a kind of
permanent underclass of the poor now and
how are we going to deal with them uh
some cities are just letting them camp
out on the streets all of these are big
problems and uh the country wants
solutions to them one of Trump's
problems going forward is that on a lot
of the issues he promised to deliver on
he didn't he did deliver on some big
issues including immigration
but I think that this sort of backward
looking revenge and the tumult that's
constantly around him will lead over
time to people going back to a prison
who was elected a century ago not a good
president Warren G Harding uh who after
uh Woodrow Wilson promised a return to
normalcy
and there's going to be a lot of people
who would like to see that well but Joe
Biden promised a bit of that and I'm not
sure we've had it but uh uh Charles we
better end it there um thank you very
much for joining us uh and thank you
very much Alan too
um uh that's it for uh the view from 22.
please tune in again next time
[Music]
foreign